[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend die große aufmerksamkeit für
die kanzler tree elle kann etwas
ärgerlich sein für jene die selbst nicht
dabei sind nach den drei halb großen
gestern hatten heute die vier kleineren
parteien ihren schlagabtausch
keiner von ihnen hat ein kanzler
kandidaten oder kandidatinnen
aufgestellt was die cs um bekanntlich in
spezieller weise schmerzt ihr ergebnis
in bayern kann für die union aber
entscheidende stimmen bringen die fdp
könnte als koalitionspartner noch sehr
gefragt werden aber auch die linke
möchte zumindest als potenzieller
koalitionspartner wahrgenommen werden
und die afc will mit möglichst vielen
abgeordneten wieder einziehen soweit die
spiel aufstellung andrea maurer hat die
vierer-runde beobachtet da möchte jemand
wissen von ihnen herr grübel wie würden
sie sich selbst wählen das ist eine sehr
gute frage selbstverständlich werde ich
mich die wehen würde wer sonst es ist
wahrscheinlich die einzige antwort auf
die sich hier heute alle hätten einigen
können am tag nach dem großen triumph
kanzleramt treffen die kleineren
parteien im zdf zollern hof zum
vierkampf aufeinander einen eigenen
kanzlerkandidaten stellt niemand von
ihnen für sie geht es bei dieser wahl
darum starke fraktion im parlament zu
sein opposition oder möglicherweise
königsmacher einer koalition erst mal
aber geht es um sehr unterschiedliche
antworten auf die drängendsten fragen
zur lage in deutschland
beispiel corona was mich wirklich
gekümmert sind vertreter dieser runde
wird die so tun als gäbe es corona gar
nicht als gäbe es keine pandemie als
wäre es die ganz normale grippe wir
wissen das ist eben nicht der fall und
deswegen müssen wir alles tun um die
impfkampagne auch jetzt entscheiden noch
voranzubringen die gesamte lockdown
politik ist völlig überzogen schadet der
wirtschaft schade und seinen
arbeitsplätzen schadet uns auch
gesellschaftspolitisch und wir sehen
dass wir begleiten das sehr sehr
kritisch dass die gesellschaft gespalten
werte in ungeimpfte und geimpfte ich
werbe für impfungen aber ich akzeptiere
auch dass menschen aus welchem grund
auch immer das nicht wollen dann müssen
sie schlicht und ergreifend sich
regelmäßig testen lassen
beispiel klimaschutz vor allem der csu
generalsekretär bemüht sich um
abgrenzung nach rechts und nach links
wir haben hier auch parteien der extreme
auch neben der frau seidel das ist eine
partei die alles leugnet die korona
leute die den klimawandel leugnen stellt
sich damit natürlich völlig außerhalb
selbstverständlich verwaltet stellen sie
sich völlig außerhalb des demokratischen
diskurses klimaschutz muss mit anreizen
funktionieren der darf auch spaß machen
die menschen dabei unterstützen aber
nicht versuchen sie umzuerziehen mit
verboten wie das von linker seite immer
gerne getan wird die afg
spitzenkandidatin spricht beim thema
klima über arbeitsplätze in der
autobranche die bewahrt werden müssen
die linke-parteichefin rechnet anders
teurer als klimaschutz ist kein
klimaschutz und die folgen des
klimawandels das sehen wir jetzt schon
also der klimawandel ist ja kein fernes
horrorszenario mehr sondern wir leben
waldbrände wir leben dürren wir leben
überschwemmungen und deswegen muss ganz
klar sein wenn wir jetzt nicht
entschieden handeln dann werden wir sehr
heftige einschnitte haben beispiel
gerechtigkeit wer soll für die sozialen
folgen der krise bezahlen afd csu und
fdp sind gegen umverteilungs maßnahmen
die linke will vermögende zur kasse
bitten ein mindestlohn von
die reichen
ich vielleicht könnten sie auch wenn wir
dauernd dazwischen zu blubbern dann darf
er jetzt auch nicht vergessen ich wohne
auch in dieser krise sind ja nicht alle
unternehmen ärmer geworden so ist es ja
nicht gibt der unternehmen die sehr gut
verdient haben in dieser krise also ob
das amazon ist oder so ein paar masken
hersteller mit hilfe von
unionsabgeordneten das was wir
umverteilen das muss verdient werden
und wenn die abgaben die staatlichen
abgaben einfach zu hoch sind dann setzt
der staat fehlanreize auf den faktor
arbeit als auch die arbeitende
bevölkerung die sich dann irgendwann mal
überlegt die steuern und abgaben sind
mir hier in deutschland viel zu hoch ich
arbeite im ausland der ton ist scharf
und wird es wohl in den nächsten 13
tagen wahlkampf bleiben was in
deutschland in den nächsten vier jahren
passieren muss die antworten der
kleineren parteien könnten
unterschiedlicher nicht sein
im trial der kanzler kandidaten und
kandidatinnen sahen die umfragen danach
erneut olaf scholz auf platz eins
jedenfalls bei überzeugungskraft oder
glaubwürdigkeit das wird im laschet
lager vielleicht nicht mehr überrascht
haben tv duelle oder tree elle sind
selten echte game changer schmerzlich
ist es für die union und ihren
spitzenmann trotzdem etwas trösten kann
er sich damit dass die cdu bei der
kommunalwahl in niedersachsen stärkste
kraft geblieben ist knapp vor der spd
das wurde von der cdu heute auch gleich
zum rückenwind erklärt wohl wissend dass
eine knappe kommunalwahl kein orkan ist
nicht nur für laschet für alle drei
kandidierenden ging es am tag danach
jedenfalls erst mal da oben sich von den
eigenen leuten ein bisschen
seelenmassage abzuholen andreas köhlers
berichtet
die frau
so richtig gerockt hat die miss nürnberg
bitte ein herzlicher empfang für aber
jeder werber für die grünen ist sie
diejenige die das tri l so richtig
gerockt hat
für die union ist er der klare gewinner
der einzige der kanzler format bewiesen
habe und die spd fand ihn am
überzeugendsten wie die meisten dieser
betriebs und personalräte in stuttgart
am tag danach auch deswegen hoffe ich
das ist dann auch klappt und dass du
dann auch demnächst wird bundeskanzler
wies danke dass du da bist auch olaf
scholz findet dass olaf scholz das tri l
gewonnen hat und fast schon den
wahlkampf ja das was du aus dem
freundes- und bekanntenkreis berichtet
berichten mir ganz viele und das merke
ich auch finde ich auf einem marktplatz
spreche oder an vielen anderen orten da
verbindet sich schon die hoffnung nach
einem aufbruch in deutschland auch mit
der entscheidung dass sich der nächste
regierungschef in deutschland werden
kann nachdem olaf scholz auch beim
zweiten evtl die blitzumfrage gewonnen
hat werden die fragen an die spd
zunehmend konkreter parteivize kevin
kühnert lässt wissen kein minister
werden zu wollen parteichefin saskia
esken weicht ein antwort dagegen weiter
aus würden sie ministerin werden wollen
bundesministerin
ich kann das bestätigen ich habe die
frage mich beantwortet hatte gestern
abend nach dem trial bekommt kandidat
scholz eine currywurst bekommt
kandidatin berbalk eine umarmung und
bekommt kandidat laschet so viel applaus
als habe er die ersehnte trendwende
tatsächlich geschafft
bei der kommunalwahl in niedersachsen
bleibt die cdu stärkste kraft und
versucht obwohl sie insgesamt stimmen
verloren hat begeistert zu sein
heute dann stehen wieder einmal
parteichef laschet und seine
dauerpräsenz stellvertreterin silvia bär
vor den journalisten die prompt wissen
wollen würden sie sich wünschen dass
jeder im präsidium mal genau diese
präsenz jetzt zeigt
also schöne frage dieses feld
alle würden das tun aber wenige haben
das glück dass ihr thema so
hervorgehoben wird wie das thema familie
das thema entlastung für familien steht
im mittelpunkt des sogenannten
sofortprogramms dass der kandidat heute
vorstellt nach dem immerhin ein
präsidiumsmitglied laschet mehr
wahlkampf präsenz zugesagt hat kanzlerin
merkel
jede
und sie entscheiden kandidatin berbalk
wünscht sich dass die wahl knapp wird
kandidat laschet beginnt wieder und
wieder die aufholjagd und für kandidat
scholz werden sie sehr lang und sehr
quälend sein die 13 tage bis zur wahl
weiter analysieren mit chuck unterlagen
banerjee ich hatte konnte lara die
parteien müssen sich ja auch fragen was
kann man in 13 tagen überhaupt noch
mobilisieren oder verlieren
ja das tun sie mit sicherheit und man
kann natürlich alles in die waagschale
werfen was man hat themen
sofortprogramme personal die union
versucht offensichtlich gerade auf den
letzten metern alles auf einmal hat auch
angela merkel wie wir es gerade eben
gehört haben schon dazu bewegt noch zwei
zusätzliche wahlkampftermine mit armin
laschet gemeinsam zu absolvieren anders
als das vorher geplant war aber auch die
grünen und die spd legen sich jetzt
natürlich nicht hin die grünen wollen
weiterhin aufholen und die spd möchte
selbstverständlich mindestens mal
bewahren was sie jetzt schon hat denn
man weiß aus vergangenen wahlkämpfen
dass immer noch viel passieren kann
diesmal ganz besonders weil die zahlen
eben die umfragen noch so offen sind da
könnten noch fehler aller kandidaten
dazu kommen die die gleichgewichte noch
einmal verschieben oder aber auch
katastrophen externe stichwort edmund
stoiber der nach der flutkatastrophe
seine chancen damals verspielt hat und
den vorsprung einbüßen musste also da
ist noch sehr vieles möglich deswegen
hört man hier in berlin übrigens auch in
den letzten tagen sehr viel häufiger als
vorher die den satz man kann übrigens
auch von platz zwei ins kanzleramt
einziehen der baum wohl die drei
führenden parteien momentan noch mal ein
wenig vor falls es nicht ganz so gut
läuft wie geplant
heißt aber auch man muss ein
koalitionspartner finden der dabei
mitmacht
ja genau das zünglein an der waage
rechnerisch braucht es ist ja momentan
immer dreier konstellation und das macht
es übrigens für parteien und wählerinnen
und wähler nicht einfacher wir haben es
heute im schlagabtausch der kleinen
parteien gesehen in allen
gedankenspielen sind ja fdp und linke
die beiden parteien die überhaupt für
koalitionen in frage kommen mit der afg
möchte keine der führt mit
spitzenkandidaten antretenden parteien
koalieren und linke und fdp liegen eben
meilenweit auseinander bei zentralen
themen gleichzeitig will sich keine
partei union nicht spd nicht und grüne
nicht genau festlegen mit wem sie sich
denn das regieren am liebsten vorstellen
würden also das macht es unterm strich
bei der wahlentscheidung nicht einfacher
dankeschön nach berlin unter der manager
alles rund um die bundestagswahl
analysen videos etwa der vierer
schlagabtausch heute das finden sie bei
uns natürlich alles immer auch online
auf zdf
beginnt die sogenannte impfwoche um mit
dem thema geht es jetzt erst mal um die
impfquote zu steigern hat die
bundesregierung mit einer bundesweiten
aktionswoche begonnen an den
unterschiedlichsten orten und ohne
termin kann sich die bevölkerung nun
impfen lassen so beispielsweise auch in
der rotkohl schule in berlin die heute
von bundespräsident steinmeier besucht
wurde er warb erneut für die kampagne
aktuell sind rund 62 prozent der
menschen in deutschland vollständig
geimpft
zu den aktuellen kroner zahlen in
deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 5511 neuinfektionen innerhalb von
24 stunden
762 mehr als am vergangenen montag zwölf
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incidents liegt bei
81,9
die schwarz rot gelbe koalition in
sachsen anhalt steht cdu spd und fdp
haben gut drei monate nach der
landtagswahl den koalitionsvertrag
unterzeichnet schwerpunkte sind unter
anderem digitalisierung strukturwandel
und der kohleausstieg am donnerstag
stellt sich ministerpräsident haseloff
im landtag zur wiederwahl
zum ersten mal seit zehn jahren ist
wieder ein israelischer
ministerpräsident offiziell nach ägypten
gereist naftali bennett traf im
küstenort sharm el-sheikh den
ägyptischen präsidenten als sie dabei
sollte es unter anderem um die
wiederbelebung des friedensprozesses
zwischen israel und den palästinensern
gehen ägypten trat schon mehrfach als
vermittler zwischen beiden seiten auf
in norwegen ist einer ersten
hochrechnung zufolge die
sozialdemokratische arbeitspartei
stärkste kraft bei der parlamentswahl
geworden die partei um ihren
vorsitzenden jonas gahr stoere kam
demnach zunächst auf etwa 26 prozent der
stimmen die konservativen der
amtierenden ministerpräsidentin einer
solberg auf etwa 20 prozent sonntag
regiert norwegen seit acht jahren
in washington muss sich außenminister
blinken zur stunde vor dem kongress
erklären zum abzug der us truppen aus
afghanistan und dem damit verbundenen
evakuierungseinsatz per webstream
zugeschaltet verteidigte blinken die
entscheidung des truppenabzugs gegenüber
den abgeordneten des auswärtigen
ausschusses
nach über 20 jahren habe es keinen
anhaltspunkt dafür gegeben dass die
afghanischen truppen aus eigener kraft
ihre sicherheit gewährleisten können
weitere jahre vor ort hätten daran
nichts geändert zu blinken
jetzt hat man an dilemma einerseits will
der westen den taliban kein geld geben
entwicklungshilfe an den afghanischen
staat gibt es bis auf weiteres keine
mehr afghanische staatskonten im ausland
wurden eingefroren andererseits will man
aber auch nicht dass in dem land eine
hungerkatastrophe ausbricht nicht nur
aus moralischen gründen da geht es
natürlich auch darum eine massenflucht
zu verhindern eine geberkonferenz der
vereinten nationen hat heute in genf
litt zusagen eingesammelt mehr als eine
milliarde dollar kamen zusammen das sind
aber wie gesagt erst mal nur zu sagen
geld fließt damit noch nicht zumal
unklar ist wie diese nothilfe zu den
menschen kommen soll ohne durch die
hände der taliban zu gehen schon vor
deren machtübernahme war afghanistan
massiv auf internationale unterstützung
angewiesen
jetzt wird die lage noch viel schlimmer
wie groß die not schon ist beschreibt
katrin eigendorf
auf der säuglingsstation des indira
gandhi kinderkrankenhauses kämpft der
kleine nummern um sein leben und
eigentlich könnte er es schaffen doch
sind zu viele die sauerstoffgeräte
reichen nicht aus es gibt nicht genug
medikamente selbst die bettchen müssen
die ärzte oft mit mehreren säuglingen
gleichzeitig belegen das kleine mädchen
ist zu früh geboren auch für sie reicht
die versorgung im krankenhaus nicht aus
es ist ein problem für uns wir haben
nicht genug medikamente nicht genug
beatmungsmaschine sie ist in kritischem
zustand ihre prognose ist nicht gut
es sind dramatische zustände und es sind
vor allem die mütter die an den betten
bangen baha ist mit ihren beiden kindern
hier sohn und tochter leiden an den
folgen schwerer unterernährung
[Musik]
ich bin so müde von dieser situation wir
besitzen nichts meine kinder ich und
mein mann uns allen geht es sehr
schlecht
dabei haben die familien die hier landen
noch glück ihre kinder können in einem
krankenhaus behandelt werden
in einem der vielen parks von kabul
campieren die die alles verloren haben
auf der flucht vor den kämpfen im land
sind sie hier gelandet ohne sauberes
wasser ohne lebensmittel schon vor der
machtübernahme der taliban afghanistan
eines der gefährlichsten und ärmsten
länder der welt vor allem für kinder
inzwischen leiden im ganzen land drei
von vier familien unter hunger ohne
internationale hilfe droht eine
katastrophe
indira gandhi krankenhaus behandeln die
ärzte kinder die an den folgen erkrankt
sind doch nicht einmal hier haben sie
genug um sie wieder aufzupäppeln
dr hc google zeigt uns baby amina ein
achtjähriges mädchen die unter
tuberkulose leidet jetzt hat sie eine
lungenentzündung ihr schicksal liegt dem
arzt besonders am herzen
ich bin sehr traurig wenn ich sehe dass
patienten in einem kritischen zustand
kommen weil wir keine mittel haben sowie
medikamente und auch keine notversorgung
e-mail-dienste jeder tag zählt sagen die
kinderärzte und auch das kinderhilfswerk
der vereinten nationen warnt vor einem
kollaps des gesundheitssystems
leidtragende wären sie die schwächsten
und dann schalten wir nochmal nach genf
dort beobachtet patricia wiedemeier für
uns die internationale geberkonferenz
für afghanistan
betrifft so etwas was wurde dazu gesagt
wie man die hilfe ins land bekommt
naja es ist ja so dass die un noch vor
ort ist und zahlreiche andere
hilfsorganisationen die alle dort noch
arbeiten aber halt mit weniger personal
die un hatte 700 mitarbeiter vor der
machtübernahme durch die taliban in
afghanistan
jetzt sind es 100 hinzu kommt dass
zahlreiche ortskräfte noch da sind und
auch arbeiten übrigens auch die frauen
teilweise von zu hause aus zweites thema
um die hilfsgüter dahin zu kriegen es
gibt eine luftbrücke schon seit längerem
seit tagen gibt es flüge zum beispiel
aus pakistan nach kandahar oder herat
und seit gestern gibt es ausflüge wieder
nach kabul die der un-generalsekretär
gut er ist hier ganz stolz erklärte und
damit könne man fast alle regionen des
landes jetzt mit hilfsgütern versorgen
nachmittags organisationen hier aber
auch gefordert das in ihre sicherheit in
irgendeiner form garantiert werden muss
und den taliban selbst scheint durchaus
bewusst zu sein dass sie da ein problem
haben
ja die taliban wissen natürlich dass sie
ohne fremde hilfe ohne hilfe von außen
vor dem größten kollaps stehen also sie
wissen es droht eine der größten
humanitären katastrophen im lande die
wirtschaft steht vor dem kollaps das
gesundheitssystem wie wir eben gehört
haben aber auch das bankensystem
mitarbeiter von hilfsorganisationen
haben wir heute abend zum beispiel
erzählt dass das ein ganz großes problem
für sie ist dass das geld eingefroren
ist dass man nicht mehr an geld rankommt
weil sie das eben brauchen um ihre
mitarbeiter zu bezahlen aber auch um zum
beispiel benzin zu kaufen ohne benzin
kann man hier natürlich nicht
transportieren und im augenblick gibt es
anscheinend kein geld um überhaupt sprit
zu kaufen also das ist ein ganz großes
problem
das wissen natürlich auch die taliban
das wirklich der kollaps des landes
droht und deswegen haben sie den
us-unterhändler versichert dass sie die
in den humanitären einsatz nicht
behindert also die hilfsgütertransporte
kommen bei den kontrollen durch die
mitarbeiter so wurde mir auch heute
abend berichtet fühlen sich noch relativ
sicher noch sind sie nicht in gefahr
noch wird der ganze humanitäre einsatz
nicht behindert und das hat die taliban
wohl auch dem unterhändler nicht nur
mündlich zugesagt sondern angeblich
sogar auf schriftlich gegeben aber wie
viel das wert ist
bezweifelt hier jeder keiner weiß wie
lange diese zusagen halten und immer
wieder war hier der satz zu hören wir
messen sie an ihren taten und nicht an
den worten danke schön vertriebs nach
genf
und jetzt nochmal ins volk wie viel
strom kommt in deutschland von welchem
energieträger also etwa wind- oder kohle
dazu gab es heute neue zahlen des
statistischen bundesamtes für die ersten
sechs monate dieses jahres frank
bethmann wie sieht diese
halbjahresbilanz aus ja sie fällt
überraschend aus ein alter bekannter die
verstromung aus kohle ist wieder auf dem
vormarsch in den ersten sechs monaten
lieferten kohlekraftwerke den meisten
strom in deutschland insgesamt kommen
die fossilen energieträger also kohle
erdgas kernenergie im ersten halbjahr
auf einen anteil an der stromerzeugung
von 56 prozent ein zuwachs von fast 21
prozent strom aus erneuerbaren also
windkraft solar biogas sank im vergleich
zum vorjahreszeitraum auf 44 prozent
nüchtern begründen energieexperten diese
entwicklung mit der windflaute im
frühjahr aber auch mit dem seit jahren
in deutschland stockenden ausbau von
windkraftanlagen
gleichzeitig wurde von januar bis juni
mehr strom verbraucht das
wiedererstarken fossile rohstoffe wie
kohle ist wegen des klimawandels
zunehmend umstritten bei der verbrennung
entsteht das klimaschädliche co2
laut bisheriger gesetzeslage soll
deutschland spätestens 20 38 ganz auf
die kohlekraft verzichten keine klagen
über zu wenig wind dagegen vom dax 91
zähler bts das aktienbarometer heute
nach oben auf 15.700 einen punkt am ende
ging dem index sogar noch etwas die
puste aus alles in allem aber dennoch
ein ordentlicher start in dieser
handelswoche frank bethmann vielen dank
ab heute können zeit karteninhaber ohne
weitere kosten das bus- und bahnangebot
des nahverkehrs teilnehmer der
verkehrsverbünde bundesweit nutzen die
aktion gilt bis einschließlich 26
september damit will sich die branche
bei ihren stammkunden bedanken die ihnen
während der pandemie die treue gehalten
haben berechtigt sind kundinnen des
öffentlichen nahverkehrs mit gültigen
abo tickets wer das angebot nutzen will
muss sich vorab online
registrieren
das finale der us open in der
vergangenen nacht in new york hat der
weltranglisten-zweite dann will medwedew
gewonnen mit 6 zu 4 6 zu 4 und 6 zu 4
gegen den weltranglisten-ersten novak
djokovic
tränen der dankbarkeit bei novak
djokovic trotz seiner niederlage gegen
den russen daniil mehr die butter vom
publikum überschwänglich gefeiert der 20
fache grand slam champion aus serbien
ist tief gerührt dabei hat er immer
wieder mit seinem spiel verpasste als
zweiter spieler den grand slam also alle
vier großen turniere innerhalb eines
jahres zu gewinnen der 25-jährige mit
leader bezwingt den weltranglisten
ersten djokovic glatt in drei sätzen und
gewinnt sein erstes grand slam turnier
überleben
dieser stoff hat mindestens das
zwanzigste jahrhundert beherrscht erdöl
entdeckt wurde es zwar schon in der
antike aber erst die industrielle
revolution hat zur massen förderung und
massen verwendung geführt und zu einer
weltweiten abhängigkeit vom auto über
nylonstrümpfe bis zur plastiktasche
überall steckt drin ein stoff um den
kriege geführt werden und mit ihm waffen
panzer fahrzeuge verbrauchen ja auch
alle öl oder werden damit hergestellt
einen kritischen blick auf dieses erdöl
zeitalter wird derzeit das kunstmuseum
wolfsburg täter kunst hat sich die
ausstellung angesehen
ein schwerer bohrkopf schwebt über
magneten vor dem öl bohrtürme von baku
aserbaidschan einst das größte ölfeld
der erde
echte kunst und echtes öl in einer
ausstellung zusammen zu bringen eine
echte herausforderung
aber das kunstmuseum wolfsburg will
zeigen dass es die moderne welt und ihre
mobilität ohne öl nicht geben würde
[Musik]
es ist der stoff von dem wir alle
abhängig wurden der uns schneller weiter
höher brachte
ja wir haben im grunde genommen in dem
bild alles verdichtet was nur mit öl
möglich ist fliegen werde nur mit öl
möglich über ist mit unmöglich der
plastikbecher ist nur mittel möglich das
heißt auch wahrscheinlich der kunststoff
bezug des polsters ist vom öl abhängig
also unser ganzes leben ist durchdrungen
von
das öl hat sich in die kulturen
eingefressen auch in den förderländern
im 18 meter langen werk des
indonesischen künstlers vihear so
vermengen sich auto und fortschritt mit
verseuchter umwelt aufgeschreckten
geistern und gepeinigten menschen
am anfang des jahrhunderts stand die
große euphorie die große
technikbegeisterung die sich aber
zunehmend dann in skepsis und den kritik
geändert gewandelt hat und im grunde
genommen haben wir natürlich heute kaum
noch ein künstler der jetzt irgendwie
unvoreingenommen sozusagen das was mit
dem öl in verbindung steht feiert zurück
auf anfang aus plastik wird wieder öl
petrochemie und fantasie prallen
aufeinander im kunststück
das ist eigentlich eine post ab gledson
lösung warum man eigentlich ölprodukten
machen kann aus plastikabfällen mit
bissigen künstler humor wird dann wieder
neues plastik draus
unzählige
menschenleben geopfert für eine plastik
nach
plastik menschen kunststoff das
langlebige öl produkt wird uns weiter
begleiten selbst wenn das erdöl
zeitalter wirklich langsam zu ende gehen
sollte die ganze welt ist ja sowas wie
das hier geworden ein wimmelbild mit
plastik
öl in der kosmetik öl als kriegs
treibstoff die allianz von schwarzen
gold und geld
durchdringt das globale leben und
fordert immer seinen preis
die ausstellung all in wolfsburg bis
januar 20 22 ist eine rasante
schrecklich schöne zeitreise auf der
ölspur
das war es von uns an diesem montagabend
gleich gehts erst noch mit dem wetter
weiter da befasst sich erst intelli
heute ausführlicher mit der frage wie
klimawandel und wirbelstürme
zusammenhängen und 2005 gibt's dann
unser heute schon mal update mit
christopher wehrmann wir melden uns
morgen wieder wieder sehen wie du sind
[Musik]
namens- und willkommen zum wetter
wirbelstürme wie hölzerne oder taifune
bilden sich über tropischen ozean und
unterscheiden sich grundlegend von
unseren stürme in europa eine
voraussetzung ist die temperatur des
ozeans die gut 27 grad betragen muss
sind alle bedingungen optimal entwickelt
sich ein sturm der sich weiter
verstärken kann und bis zur höchsten
kategorie 5 an steigt dann herrschen
windgeschwindigkeiten im sturm von 252
kilometer pro stunde und mehr durch die
fortschreitende erhitzung der ozeane
haben die stürme mehr wärme zur
verfügung so steigt dadurch die
zerstörungskraft weiter an die
wissenschaft bestätigt diese stärksten
stürme werden stärker und häufiger dazu
verläuft die entwicklung dieser stürme
in einem rasanten tempo
und der ehemalige super taifun chan to
ist sozusagen über zu warmes wasser
gezogen und ist jetzt gestrandet
zwischen shanghai und südkorea und wird
erst dann am donnerstag dort wegziehen
und große regenmengen produzieren ja
anders bei uns in deutschland recht
ruhiges wetter mit viel nebel 7 bis 15
grad die tiefsten temperaturen und
morgen erst einmal relativ freundliches
wetter zum späten nachmittag kommt von
süden schauer und gewitter auf ansonsten
ist aber auch nebel dabei bei höchsten
temperaturen von 28 grad im südwesten
deutschlands und 19 grad an den küsten
ja und schauer und gewitter gibt es am
mittwoch auch 26 grad und danach nicht
mehr ganz so warm ein schöner abend